I would say probably my court intuition
is it's as real as I mean in very many
different domains but you know somebody
I mean and I think there's an objective
truth there I mean in that sense I think
realism has to answer for you know its
kind of answers itself it's sort of
because if somebody you know disagrees
with me about real as a little they'd
say well that's what's really real you
know that's fit it's it's it's hard to
not somehow come down on the side of
objective truth and and realism but it's
an entirely different proposition to say
that we can know reality and that we are
ever certain of the truth I think way
often people merge the question of
whether there's truth whether realism is
true with the epistemological question
of whether we can know the truth and
whether we can you know everybody
certain of it and you know in there
that's totally different question and I
would say yeah no I mean the truth if we
know anything about it or anything is
there anything that we ought to know
about it says very hard to come by to me
it's pretty amazing
given our evolutionary roots right that
we are evolved chimps basically then we
know anything at all you know and that
we have developed these self-critical
methodologies both philosophy and and
science and the social scientists as
well to interrogate ourselves and so
that we we do a approach closer and
closer to you know something in the
truth you know I do I do think that
there's a tremendous amount that we
don't know and possibly can never know
so that affect my realism commits me to
that right I think you know because I
think there really is a reality it's you
know some some get a little glimmers of
it if we're very very strict with
ourselves and we're really interrogate
our own beliefs and we pool our shared
knowledge and pool our resources that
you know we can know something I think
it's probably very little but but enough
for us to believe in truth so yeah by
talking about intuitions what I'm doing
is talking about the limits on our own
knowledge making it more of a claim
about knowledge rather than truths that
make sense and two questions one is
and you give in a small example of what
you think is quite like something that
we know is real like yes yeah I think we
really do know that there are laws of
nature and that we don't know all of
them and we don't know why they are the
laws of nature but we do know something
about the laws of nature through science
and always we know it's not the last
word we correcting ourselves there was
Newton okay mine Steinem tivity theory -
correct
Newton to show that it was only a
limiting case and when if we take
velocities that are very large that you
know Newtonian mechanics breaks and also
when we're dealing with things that are
moving very very fast I just said that
yes when we're taking philosophies that
are very large or quantum mechanics that
we're dealing with a very very small
Newtonian physics breaks down so you
know each at each stage all we can say
is we have an approximation of the laws
of nature we keep pushing and pushing in
and we find out it's just an
approximation we're back to the drawing
boards but I do think we know that there
are laws of nature it's an orange
self-interest to discover the laws of
nature I think for example we know on
the basis of pretty solid science not
terribly sophisticated that the climb
that the climate is is warming we
understand why it's warming we
understand what carbon emissions are
doing it was interestingly predicted on
the basis of shear Theory 1896 by
Swedish physicist Arenas who said you
know this could happen in like another
400 years right you know that burning
coal and such things are going to trap
moisture
going to create a sealing trap moisture
and it's all going to warm up you know
happen a little faster than he thought
but I think we know this and we know why
it happened it was predicted so I think
we know that there are laws of nature
that they govern physical reality and
that we know some of these physical laws
well enough to make predictions and and
to try to counteract what is bad for the
survival of our planet and all the
creatures on and I think we really know
this I don't think it's I think that
some of the controversies that took
place and very much in the 1960s 1970s
around Thomas Kuhns book the structure
scientific revolution big book most a
signed book still in American
universities you know that there's no
science doesn't make progress that it's
always you know there are these paradigm
shifts that are akin to a religious
conversion and you just change your
frame you change the game blah blah blah
I think I think this was wrong it was
very very fashionable and and it was it
seeped out into the intellectual
atmosphere in such a way that people you
know doubted the expertise of science in
any way I mean only thing that was wrong
here's another sphere altogether you
know I think we know that slavery is
wrong it took us a really long time to
figure that out
great great thinkers like Plato and
Aristotle whose great moral thinkers we
tend to revere you know Alfred North
Whitehead said all of whole history of
Western philosophy consists of footnotes
to Plato well he started methodology but
he didn't know he never thought to
question the institution of slavery I
think we know that it's wrong it's
absolutely wrong for people to take
possession of other people nobody has
the right to do that I think we know a
lot of things about rights
and so here I'm so the two quite
different examples one scientific one
moral and I think that we know these
things for more debates talks and
interviews subscribe today to the
Institutes of arson ideas her IAI TV
you